los puntos de la siguiente gráfica
representan una función bueno pues para
que los puntos representen una función a
cada coordenada en x deben de asignarle
una única coordenada en g es decir si a
éste le pongo el eje x ya éste le pongo
el eje déjame llamarle fx necesitamos
que para cada valor de x haya un único
valor de fx esto parece una función efe
de x pero vamos a pensar que todavía no
sabemos si si lo es o no lo es vale
vamos a averiguarlo entonces estos
puntos que nos dicen por ejemplo este
este es el punto de coordenadas menos
1,3 esto lo que nos dice es que f
efe de menos 1 es igual a 3 hasta
ahorita efe todavía podría hacer función
simplemente esto nos está diciendo que
al menos uno le toca el menos 3 vamos
con los demás puntos este de acá esté
acá es el punto 2 - 2 vale entonces de
manera similar esto lo que nos dice es
que f de 2 es igual a menos 2 todavía no
tenemos ningún problema el menos uno se
va al 3 el 2
al menos 2 este es este tercer punto es
el 3 2
así que también tenemos efe de 3 es
igual a 2 y mira hasta ahorita no hemos
tenido ningún problema si tuviéramos
nada más estos puntos
efe por supuesto que sería función sin
embargo estos dos puntos como que echan
a perder las cosas déjame déjame
marcarlos con este color rosa entonces
este de acá es el punto 4 545 y este ya
que es el 4 menos 14 menos 1 entonces ya
tenemos dos valores de iu para un mismo
valor de x esto lo que nos dice es que
la función f
no va a ser función déjame escribirlo
por acá
bueno la relación pues no va a ser
función entonces escribiéndolo en
términos de f nos quedaría que f de 4 es
igual a 5 y que f de 4
efe de 4 es igual a menos 1 y por lo
tanto f no es función sale a 4 le está
asignando dos valores así que no sé a
cuál me tengo que ir otra forma de ver
esto es aquí en la gráfica podemos
trazar una línea vertical que pase por
aquí
y podemos darnos cuenta que al 4 le
estamos asignando 2 valores el menos 1 y
el 5 entonces este es un criterio útil
cuando tenemos la gráfica podemos trazar
una línea vertical vale bueno la
conclusión la escribo por acá es que f
efe
no es función no es función o sea los
puntos de la gráfica no determinan una
función vale le pongo signos de
admiración